LOOK HERE AT WHAT A KIM-TRUMP
SUMMIT MIGHT LOOK LIKE.
>> Reporter: THE UNCERTAINTY
OF PLANNING A MEETING BETWEEN
TWO UNPREDICTABLE USERS.
>> IT MAY NOT HAPPEN QUICKLY, IT
MAY HAPPEN LATER, BUT THE
PRESIDENT IS READY.
>> THEY ARE STILL TARGETING A
JUNE 12 MEETING IN SINGAPORE
BETWEEN PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
KIM JONG UN.
THEY ARE COORDINATING WITH THE
U.S. ON PLANNING DESPITE THREATS
TO CANCEL THE SUMMIT.
U.S. AND NORTH KOREAN OFFICIALS
WILL TRY TO AGREE ON HOW KIM
SURRENDERS HIS NUCLEAR PROGRAM,
WHAT NORTH KOREA RECEIVES IN
RETURN AND WHEN IT WILL RECEIVE
IT.
A TOP STATE DEPARTMENT DIPLOMAT
HAS JUST FLOATED A PLAN WHERE
NORTH KOREA WOULD OFFER A BIG
DOWN PAYMENT.
ACCORDING TO SUSAN THORTON, THE
ACTIVE SECRETARY OF STATE FOR
EAST PACIFIC AFFAIRS, THE
QUESTION IS, WHAT COULD BE
FRONTLOADED IN THE PROCESS THAT
IS INEVITABLY GOING ON FOR
SOMETIME?
AND WHAT WOULD BE ACCEPTABLE TO
THE NORTH KOREAN SIDE IN
RESPONSE TO THAT OFF-LOADING?
THIS IS WHY I WILL DO ALL I CAN
TO PREVENT SUSAN THORTON FROM
BEING SECRETARY OF STATE.
SHE'S IN TOKYO, UNDERMINING
POTUS BY ADVOCATING FOR PARTIAL
NUKES IN NORTH KOREA.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT SAYS
THORNTON'S FULL COMMENTS MATCH
SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE POMPEO'S
POSITION.
>> WHAT SUSAN THORTON IS TALKING
ABOUT IS VERY SIMILAR AND THE
SAME THING THAT SECRETARY POMPEO
SPOKE ABOUT, AND THAT IS, WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE A BIGGER,
BOLDER, DIFFERENT, FASTER DEAL
THAN THE KIND OF DEALS THAT HAVE
BEEN PROPOSED BEFORE.
>> THE UNITED STATES WANTS AN
UPFRONT DEMONSTRATION, BEYOND
PROMISES FROM KIM JONG UN THAT
HE IS WILLING TO SURRENDER HIS
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
THE SOUTH KOREAN GOVERNMENT,
ALSO A TARGET OF COMPLAINTS HAS